Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Uragano Ida.
New York, 1 settembre 2021.
Tutti noi abbiamo visto questa immagine;
ma pochi sanno che, al di là
degli uragani e dei venti,
c'è stata un'emergenza molto più forte:
tempesta di topi.
Vedo che non sono l'unica scioccata
dal vedere un'immagine simile;
ma poiché voglio trattare, oggi,
della crisi climatica
e di come questa sia il motore
di nuovi e preoccupanti
fenomeni migratori,
ho necessità di portarvi
in quella esperienza che io ho vissuto.
Infatti ho 26 anni, e faccio parte
di quella categoria di persone
che dicono di poter vivere
una certa ansia climatica;
e questa ansia climatica
deriva dal vivere in un mondo
dove quasi viene meno la possibilità
di sognare e anche progettare.
Ovviamente la storia che vi racconterò
riguarda me e loro;
però, poiché voglio che vi concentrate
molto di più sulle mie parole
che non su questa immagine,
passo a quella successiva,
che è un'immagine
che appunto ci fa ridere,
ci fa sorridere,
che sembra familiare un po' per tutti.
Però questa immagine
mi ha fatto molto riflettere.
Io vivo a New York,
una città famosa per avere
più topi che abitanti,
e ci sono 6.000.000 di persone.
Vedo qualcuno che annuisce,
quindi non sono l'unica
ad essere stata traumatizzata da questo.
La cosa che per me è diventata normale
è stata quella di vedere
fiumi e fiumi di topi
riunirsi negli angoli delle città,
laddove si possono osservare
queste nuove sculture moderne
di fiumi e fiumi e sacchetti di immondizia
tutti quanti raccolti.
Però, quello che io
non consideravo normale
era pensare di avere
dei ratti nel mio appartamento,
e io vivevo al ventesimo piano.
Ovviamente, inutile dirvi che ho fatto
il trasloco più veloce della storia;
però questo mi ha fatto pensare,
mi ha fatto molto pensare
perché prima di partire
per questa mia nuova esperienza
ricordo di aver letto un articolo,
che diceva di come l'Australia,
a seguito dei numerosi incendi
che vi erano stati,
era costretta ad affrontare un'emergenza
legata proprio ai ratti,
che si spostavano da un punto all'altro
fino a diffondere nuove malattie.
E per me queste malattie
erano troppo lontane,
e a volte anche il fenomeno climatico
è qualcosa che viviamo
e che sembra non toccarci.
Però, una volta trovati
dei ratti nel mio appartamento
allora sì, per me
sono diventati un problema;
e ho iniziato a documentarmi,
e ho visto come non solo in Australia,
non solo a New York,
ma anche qui in Italia
abbiamo un problema simile.
E qual è il più grande problema?
Che a seguito di una pandemia
potremmo avere una nuova emergenza.
Poi ho pensato:
in realtà, a livello storico
noi già abbiamo una testimonianza
di un popolo che purtroppo si è estinto
per ragioni climatiche,
e soprattutto a causa dei topi:
l'Isola di Pasqua.
Molti, quando parlano
dell'Isola di Pasqua,
e delle ragioni per cui il popolo
è dovuto allontanarsi,
oppure si è estinto,
sono legate a queste sculture
che vedete alle mie spalle, i Moai.
In realtà, pochi sanno
che la popolazione si è estinta
soprattutto per la mancanza di viveri
e per la mancanza di acqua potabile,
e la mancanza di viveri e di acqua
era dovuta principalmente a questi cargo
che arrivavano dal Vecchio
Continente al nuovo
e che trasportavano soprattutto ratti;
e i ratti hanno diffuso nuove malattie,
oltre ad aver mangiato i raccolti.
Questo mi porta, quindi,
ad una riflessione più ad ampio respiro,
che è quella della crisi climatica.
E allora inizio con alcuni dati:
l'un percento della Terra, nel 2019,
è stato dichiarato inabitabile,
e tra il 2008 e il 2018
circa 26 milioni di persone
sono state costrette a spostarsi,
ovviamente per mancanza di viveri,
per mancanza di acqua
e per diffusione di malattie rare.
Quindi parliamo di diritti fondamentali.
E allora, questo mi porta
ad analizzare il tema di oggi:
rifugiati climatici,
o migranti ambientali.
Ma chi sono i rifugiati climatici?
Ecco, questa è la prima domanda.
E da giurista, vi dico che il problema
è che manca una definizione
della stessa categoria.
L'unico spiraglio di speranza che abbiamo
è quella di analizzare
i due termini singolarmente.
Allora, per quanto riguarda
la parola "rifugiato"
vi è la Convenzione di Ginevra del 1951,
che lega questa particolare categoria
alle guerre, alle violenze,
alle persecuzioni;
e quindi sembrerebbe quasi impossibile
darne un'interpretazione
di tipo estensivo,
fino a ricomprendere
questa nuova categoria.
E allora,
il termine viene ad essere utilizzato
nei fori internazionali,
viene ad essere utilizzato
nelle discussioni pubbliche;
ma nei fatti, nulla
è possibile al momento.
Certo, c'è chi tenta di dare
un'interpretazione di tipo estensivo,
ma lo fa quasi in maniera sorda:
ossia, un'agenzia delle Nazioni Unite
autorevole, l'UNEP,
nel 1985 ha dato una prima definizione
di "rifugiato climatico",
e ha detto che questa categoria
è legata a particolari circostanze,
ossia eventi che costringono persone
a spostarsi in maniera
temporanea o permanente
per la mancanza di possibilità
e progetti futuri
di vivere una vita normale.
Quindi ancora parliamo
di diritti fondamentali.
E adesso passiamo al secondo tema,
quello del clima.
Inizio da una differenza
che è quella tra "Climate" e "Weather",
ossia tra clima e tempo atmosferico.
Questo è di particolare importanza
perché devo dire che io sarò
anche petulante sul cambiamento climatico,
e mi sta bene,
però molte persone mi dicono:
in realtà il clima non è un vero problema,
il clima è sempre cambiato
e di questo ne abbiamo testimonianza.
Questo è vero, ma il reale problema
è che le cose cambiano
in maniera troppo veloce;
e questo sì, che riguarda tutti noi.
Allora per "tempo atmosferico"
si intende una variazione,
anche abbastanza ampia,
in gradi centigradi,
però nel breve periodo;
mentre il clima riguarda il lungo periodo.
Detto in altre parole,
se una differenza di dieci
gradi centigradi in una giornata
ci può sembrare
anche quasi normale,
una differenza di dieci gradi centigradi
in tre, quattro, cinque anni,
questo ci preoccupa.
Questa è una prima definizione importante.
Il secondo punto che vorrei sottolineare
è questa sorta di vaghezza dei termini
che vengono ad essere utilizzati
e che affollano le nostre pagine.
Il primo è il "global warming",
e a sentire questa espressione
la prima immagine che abbiamo
è quello di un mondo che brucia.
E questo è un problema,
perché anziché pensare
ad un mondo che bruci
dovremmo pensare ad una serie
di energie che vengono rilasciate,
e che quindi creano zone
del mondo estremamente calde
ed altre zone fredde,
con alluvioni sempre più ripetute.
Invece, il cambiamento climatico
è una categoria, possiamo dire,
"di ampio respiro",
che guarda a tutta una serie di fenomeni
che sono legati a queste
variazioni di lungo periodo;
e tra questi, ovviamente,
rientrano i rifugiati climatici.
Questa immagine secondo me è molto forte,
perché ci permette di capire
quanto l'uomo abbia la possibilità
di cambiare le cose,
ma soprattutto di quanto l'uomo
abbia una presa sulla natura.
Sono bastati pochi giorni
di chiusura forzata in casa
per vedere come l'ambiente
abbia risposto in maniera positiva;
e quasi ci sembrava sbalorditivo ammettere
che quei risultati, tanto sperati
e voluti dalla ricerca,
potessero realizzarsi
nel giro di pochi momenti,
o nel giro di pochi giorni.
E allora ho pensato:
ma forse il problema è che siamo
veramente circondati
da una serie di informazioni catastrofiche
al punto tale da allontanarci fin troppo
da questo che è un problema
che io reputo visibile
e presente ai nostri occhi.
E allora ho pensato:
come ho iniziato ad interessarmi
dei rifugiati climatici?
Come è partito il mio
interesse per il clima?
Ed è partito con l'uragano Katrina.
Ero una bambina e guardavo
queste immagini,
che per me erano assolutamente devastanti.
Poi però, crescendo, ho visto
come l'intensità degli uragani aumentasse;
ma le informazioni che venivano diffuse
diventavano sempre più vaghe,
e le informazioni più vaghe
le ho ritrovate
proprio per ciò che riguarda
l'uragano Maria.
Ma non mi è bastato
leggere le informazioni:
sono voluta andare sul posto,
e sono andata su uno dei posti
più colpiti dall'uragano Maria,
che è Puerto Rico.
La cosa che però ho imparato, ancora,
è avere una conferma che l'agire umano
sia assolutamente determinante.
Ho incontrato persone
che avevano perso tutto,
ma che hanno avuto la forza
di cambiare il proprio stile di vita.
E questo mi riporta ad un'immagine
che potrebbe essere
tra le tante che vediamo
anche scorrendo le nostre bacheche social,
ossia di tanti giovani
che scendono in strada,
vòlti a cambiare il loro Paese.
E allora qui mi ricollego all'espressione
che ho utilizzato all'inizio del mio talk,
ossia "ansia climatica".
Noi giovani viviamo l'ansia
di non poter progettare,
ma sarebbe sbagliato pensare
che solo noi giovani
siamo chiamati a cambiare le cose.
Ed infatti bisognerebbe
scendere in strada, certo,
ma anche coinvolgere i propri genitori,
coinvolgere le persone più piccole,
e quindi smettere di parlare
di un discorso che sia
semplicemente generazionale.
Noi oggi viviamo crisi multiple:
vi è la pandemia,
vi è l'emergenza climatica;
e soprattutto,
quest'anno abbiamo avuto prova
di come questa emergenza
non sia tanto lontana da noi.
Quindi tutti gli Stati, nessuno escluso,
nell'ultima decade ha dovuto
interfacciarsi con una crisi climatica;
e tutti noi, nessuno escluso,
è chiamato a fare qualcosa.
Bene, dopo questo bel discorso
allora voi mi potreste chiedere:
ma cosa possiamo fare?
A livello tecnico mi sento di dire
che la cosa migliore sarebbe attuare
le cosiddette "Sharing Technologies",
ossia condividere quelle che sono
le informazioni al momento presenti,
soprattutto sul mercato,
di quelle che potrebbero
essere le tecnologie
che più possono aiutare
i paesi succubi di questo clima,
che sembra diventare sempre più violento.
E il secondo punto,
che forse è quello su cui tutti noi
possiamo realmente agire,
già l'ho citato,
è l'educazione:
ossia insegnare ai più piccoli,
ma anche ai meno piccoli,
che noi tutti non siamo
qualcosa di altro dalla natura.
Noi siamo parte stessa della natura,
per cui qualunque nostro agire
avrà delle ripercussioni.
Si dice che noi siamo ciò che mangiamo;
ma io aggiungerei che siamo, anche,
il risultato dell'ambiente
che ci circonda.
Questo vale per le persone,
e per la natura.
Grazie.
(Applausi)